the holiday week here in the United
States has unfortunately sadly had a
very very violent start but I guess not
really unexpectedly if you just kind of
understand the numbers and know what it
is that happens in the United States
just about every single day we we know
that emotions run more highly for some
people around the holidays in the United
States we know that depression and
anxiety and even depending on which
studies you look at even suicidal
ideation increases during this period
that's basically between Thanksgiving
week this week and New Year's December
31st January first and since in the
United States more and more it's guns
that are seen as a way to solve problems
that people might have for worse not for
better this is exactly what we would be
afraid of happening and indeed yesterday
Monday for mass shootings on the same
day discovered on the same day although
we don't yet know for sure if all four
were perpetrated on the same day in
Chicago at a hospital a doctor was shot
to death by a gunman who entered the
building killed a pharmaceutical
assistant and a police officer after
shooting the doctor outside the hospital
and then ended up dead himself the
shooter knew the doctor and according to
one report was the doctor's ex-fiance
the 28 year old police officer that died
in that incident was married with
children going from Chicago to Denver
Colorado one dead and four injured with
bullet wounds with a suspect still at
large as of just a few hours ago that
shooting took place out on a street
corner in a pretty nice part of Denver
moving then to st. Louis Missouri where
at a religious supply store a shooter
sexually assaulted a woman shot a woman
in the head and that victim later died
in the hospital this was at Catholic
supply of st. Louis in western st.
Western st. Louis again as of a few
hours ago the shooter on the loose
looking for a five-foot seven inch tall
man with
heavy build it's not known at this point
why this store were there connections
between the shooter and victims whether
religion played a role it was again a
religious supply store and then lastly
Philadelphia two men and two women found
shot dead in the basement of a house
being renovated they're being called
executions because the victims appear to
have been led to the basement and killed
there no signs of struggle none of the
people were tied up or anything like
that and this is just yesterday one day
Monday November 19th
was it 2018 and it's important to
remember that mass shootings are
horrible and tragic and yet they are
only about two percent of annual gun
deaths mass shootings account for under
two percent of annual gun deaths most
shooting deaths are individuals and yes
I know the right likes to point out that
a majority of those are suicides and I
hate to tell you that in addition to
these four mass shootings yesterday
there were 41 other shooting incidents
if you look at the data on gun violence
archive.org most individual shootings
one victim not always someone who dies
sometimes just injured so this is a
problem that is really many problems and
that's why Pat when I hear the rights
say oh but most shootings are merely
suicides as if in that case we don't
have to worry well no we should be
working on reducing suicide by gun
suicide in general we should be working
on reducing single handgun homicides and
we should be working on reducing mass
shootings it's just that the the tactics
may be different for each that doesn't
mean we only care about one or the other
right I also think that far fewer
suicide attempts would be successful if
something else was used aside from a gun
but that's maybe a separate point we
could do a segment like this every day
today in mass shootings and if you
notice that even the mass shootings were
in like upwards of 10
fifteen people are killed when those
happen it's not the news that it used to
be I mean Virginia Tech Columbine Sandy
Hook that really captured the news cycle
for weeks and months on ends now we have
one more freak we have them more
frequently and they don't really capture
the spotlight for too long yeah even the
big ones that we have and we've had some
of the biggest ones in American history
over the last 12 to 18 months they still
dominate the news cycle but for not
nearly as long of a time mass shootings
still common in that they involve
targeting of schools and workplaces what
is not super common is for a good guy
with a gun to intervene I mean that's
simply the truth the right will say if
more good guys with guns were around
they'd have more of a chance at
intervening that has not been borne out
by the statistics thus far beyond
anecdotal cases one way or the other
it's shaping up to be a disastrous
holiday sadly